Timothy force looks to major in English
and minor in economics in Latin he has a
3.6 for grade point average his future
plans include business ownership and
farming on campus he volunteers for a
few good men belongs to the Catholic
society and works as a house director in
the Suites he also plays on the club
soccer team beside his campus activities
he assists with a youth ministry at the
st. anthony catholic church he
previously belonged to the Boy Scouts
where he reached the rank of Eagle Tim
is the third of four children his
younger brother is a post-secondary
student the family resides in Colorado
Springs Colorado his father is employed
employed in sales and his mother is
self-employed thank you dr. Whelan Thank
You Larissa I would also like to thank
grounds and maintenance for this
wonderful set up on the east lawn and
finally I'd like to thank the college's
horticulturalist Angie for the work she
does for this school including the
arrangements you see here today I am
truly humbled to speak before all of you
today but I would like to spare you any
sort of congratulations you already know
that you have the envy of all your dad's
friends who watch conservative talk
radio and I already know that you know
that Hillsdale is the best college in
the nation for goodness sakes if the
trend is continuing then you are the
most intelligent class at this school
has ever admitted which means that you
had options lots of options and yet you
are sitting here so in lieu of
congratulations congratulating you for
something that you already know is a
spectacular accomplishment I would like
to simply share with you the single most
formative thing that I have learned
during my time here this important
lesson had like most important lessons
been a lifetime in the making but the
most crucial steps were not taken into
my own freshman convocation the day that
I entrusted my education in the liberal
arts to Hillsdale College my freshman
year far exceeded my expectations my
high school senior bravado was certainly
knocked down a couple notches by
rigorous academics and my increased
independence showed me that my parents
had done much more for me than I had
ever known despite these couple of tough
realizations my first semester here at
Hillsdale pushed me to a before unknown
level
of intellectual activity dr. Cal Toph
made his western heritage class consider
the nature of the well-ordered life dr.
gaetano gave his American heritage class
way too much information about the
private life of William Byrd and he
warned us about the dangerous ideas of
those who wish to imitate eyes the
eschaton I cannot wait for you all to
understand what I just alluded to and
dr. Linley showed his great books class
that Polyphemus the Cyclops is not
simply one of Homer's mythical creatures
but also a lesson to readers that we
have two eyes for a reason and the
perspective provided by these two eyes
should not be wasted I somewhat
mistakenly believe that coming to
understand these ideas was the sole
reason I attended this prestigious
academic institution it was not into my
sophomore year and one of dr. she
leaders philosophy classes that a single
sentence showed me that Hillsdale was
offering me much more if only I would
let it the sentence comes from an
incredible 1965 document called gaudiya
med spez which translates from the Latin
into joy and hope it's a lovely title
the sentence reads man who is the only
creature on earth which God willed for
itself cannot fully find himself except
through a sincere gift of himself I am
not equipped to dissect all the
intricacies of this statement plus I do
not want to burden you with a lengthy
digression but I can tell you that it
was largely this statement that formed
the man standing before you today if I
may I would like to dial back the
philosophical tenure of the sentence and
paraphrase it as a human being due to
his likeness to God is unlike any other
created thing and therefore does not
fully become a human being until he can
selflessly give himself to something
other than himself naturally I needed to
take this paraphrase one step further
and read the sentence as I Tim Force
profoundly and beautifully resemble my
Creator in order to become what my
Creator intended me to be I must fully
submit my life to things and people
other than myself I might just be a nerd
but seriously this changes everything
first of all it radically altered my
perception of hillsdale's liberal arts
education I discovered that the reality
of the liberal arts is not contained in
Lane Kendall Stroh Sakura dau but rather
the classroom simply provides us with
the raw materials with which we can
fully understand ourselves it is then
our responsibility to steward these raw
materials and by means of conversation
and reflective thought learn who we are
and who we ought to be once we come to a
fuller understanding of ourselves then
we can willingly and holistically give
our lives to other people or pursuits
secondly this lesson I learned about
giving myself to other change the way I
perceive hardship I'm not going to
sugarcoat this when the last couple of
weeks of each semester roll around you
will be tired you will be homesick and
you will probably wonder why you
willingly pay for the end of the
semester abuse having felt all those
feelings six times I can tell you that
it was that what I was feeling was
really just cleverly disguised egoism
and those closing weeks of the semester
I'm prone to forget that my primary
concern should not be my GPA my
reputation and my desire to get home
rather I should strive to be fully
myself and to do this I must recommit
myself to giving my life to the higher
calling of education to my close friends
who continually give their lives to me
to my parents who simply want to know
that they are loved and appreciated and
to all the other people who I should be
treating as neighbors I promise you that
this is easier said than done but if on
a daily basis you can sincerely recommit
yourself to those people and purposes
then your egoism will not fuel your
self-pity during those difficult
situations I feel inclined to warn you
that this sort of radical gift of self
is not always possible by human means
alone so I implore you to nurture a
vibrant prayer life a prayer life in
which you can give yourself to divine
and with which you can ask God for the
graces to give yourself to other people
and purposes I would now like to cite
three concrete examples of the joy and
fulfillment of a life lived for others
my first example comes from an
experience I had early in my freshman
year one night after a particularly
disheartening attempt to write a paper
in the old student union lab I started a
dejected 3am walk back to Simpson 1fn I
intended to Walla winsome self-pity
before getting some well need
sleep but my hallmate you I West had a
different idea Eli saw my vulnerability
and other than exploiting it he decided
to share his own vulnerabilities only
God knows why he was awake at that
horrible hour but instead of focusing on
his own troubles he gifted his life to
me by means of a short prayer and his
time Eli taught me a critical lesson
about self gift that night and for that
he should be giving this speech but at
the very least find him and if you live
on his Hall in Simpson you have an
invaluable friend my second example
comes from my sophomore roommate Tyler
Wilkie the men of need filled
endearingly called him Haas which was
fitting because he practically sweat
self gift almost every weekend he would
make the five hour trip to his family's
farm in northern Illinois ten cattle and
harvest crops for two days start his
homework around eleven o'clock Sunday
night and amazingly be prepared for
class on Monday if that is not enough he
helped build sets for the drama
department and was a key volunteer in a
few good men he even went so far as to
how haul a plow truck from his farm to
Hillsdale and he enlisted me to
voluntarily plow ten driveways any time
it snowed that is a big commitment in
south central michigan you might be
saying that it does not sound like
academics or his top priority and you
would be right he put much before his
school work yet as we speak he is
working through his second year at drake
law school Tyler Wilkie taught me how
that somehow it is possible to never be
too busy to give yourself to others my
third example comes from a very recent
experience come next Sunday my wife and
I will have shared three full and happy
months of marriage that sentence from
Gowdy Emmett's bez truly came into focus
as I stood with her before the altar and
now every day I enjoy her gift of self
to me and I get to continually practice
giving myself to her I can tell you with
certainty that the most important date
in the last four years of my life will
not be my first or last day here at
Hillsdale but rather June 4th the day
that Perry Rose taught me the full
meaning of that powerful sentence from
gaudiya meds bez I thank all of you for
your time and your decision to join in
the partnership of hillsdale college I
would like to leave you with this the
best gift that you can give this
institution and certainly the best gift
that you can give any person is your
unreserved and through
see astok and joyful self thank you and
good luck